[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 11 janvier voici
les titres plus de 300 plaintes déposées
depuis l'instauration du pass sanitaire
selon le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin les élus sont devenus la cible
récurrente de violence 60 ont même été
menacé devant rien que sur ce début
d'année et des faits qui concernent dans
les yvelines certains maires et
parlementaires le crid alerte de
l'établissement français du sang les
stocks de produits sanguins sont à un
niveau critique jamais vu et le contexte
sanitaire n'arrange en rien la situation
explications avec le directeur de l'efs
s ile de france enfin la population
yvelinoise a connu légère hausse entre
2013 et 2019 le département contre 1
million 448000 207 habitants selon
l'insee que retenir de ce chiffre
comment l'expliquez nous poserons toutes
ces questions au directeur régional
adjoint de l'institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques
un député la république en marge de
saint pierre et miquelon agressé devant
chez lui dimanche c'est l'un des
derniers événements révélateur de ce
climat de tension envers les élus et
depuis l'instauration du pass sanitaire
qui va devenir bientôt passe vaccinale
1186 aurait été pris pour cible sur les
onze premiers mois de 2000 21 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur et des menaces
et violences que connaissent aussi
plusieurs élus du territoire yvelinois
le reportage de mélanie poquet de
nicolas landry
aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines comparé à
une femme tondue après la seconde guerre
mondiale dans un tweet au compte
aujourd'hui suspendu bruno millièmes
député de la 9e circonscription menacée
de mort depuis l'annoncé d'un projet de
loi pour un pass vaccinale les élus de
la majorité sont pris à partie comme il
ya une brawn pie v qui a reçu plusieurs
menaces par mail et par lettre
manuscrite ces deux dernières semaines
d'inquiétude un peu de colère en fait
parce que l'inquiétude parce qu'on voit
que certaines de ces personnes qui font
ces menaces la passe à l'acte il ne
s'arrête pas à ce qui est déjà une
infraction pénale intimidations les nas
et puis la colère parce que lorsque vous
vous engager en politique vous avez des
attentions de servir de servir vos
concitoyens de servir l'intérêt général
vous faites le mieux que vous pouvez
dans cet engagement là qui est un très
bel engagement et vous n'imaginez à
aucun moment que cet engagement va vous
conduire à cette inquiétude moi je suis
plutôt de ce que ça renforce parce que
vous ne pouvez pas laisser le débat
public être ainsi des voiliers vous ne
pouvez pas laisser ces individus quels
qu'ils soient
abaissées ce débat est finalement le
réduire à néant donc je crois que il est
de notre rôle à nous qui avons décidé de
nous engager dans notre vie publique de
nous battre de défendre le débat est
inlassablement de rappeler que tout doit
se résoudre par le dialogue et par la
démocratie
face à ces dernières semaines sous
tension aurore bergé a lancé un cri
d'alert la député appelle à un front
commun un sentiment partagé par la
présidente de la commission des lois il
ya aussi est évidemment la réponse
judiciaire dans le sens où on ne peut
pas laisser passer de telles agressions
ne peut pas laisser passer une telle
violence donc il faut la condamner il
faut la condamner dans les tribunaux il
faut la condamner publiquement lorsqu'on
est responsable politique et sans
conditionnalité ce mardi 11 janvier le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand réuni en soirée les
ministres de l'intérieur et de la
justice pour faire un point sur ces
violences et sur la réponse judiciaire a
apporté
le proviseur adjoint d'un établissement
de lyme est visé par des tirs de
mortiers les faits se sont produits hier
lundi devant le lycée condorcet vers
8h15 un groupe de jeunes entend démarrer
un blocus du site prétextant la
situation sanitaire quatre d'entre eux
tentent même de mettre feu à des
poubelles c'est à ce moment
qu'intervient le principal adjoint il
est la cible à cinq ou six reprises deux
tirs de mortier et touché une fois dans
le dos fort heureusement sans être
blessé les quatre individus ont été
rapidement interpellé trois de ces
jeunes âgés de 16 ans sont élèves au
lycée est inconnu des services de police
un protocole sanitaire assouplie dans
les écoles le premier ministre jean
castex a annoncé ce lundi trois mesures
les parents pourront désormais venir
chercher leurs enfants en fin de journée
lorsqu'un cas positifs et déceler dans
une classe lorsqu'un enfant est qu'à
contacter il pourra se soumettre
seulement à trois auto test qui en plus
seront donnés gratuitement en pharmacie
sur attestation délivrée par l'école
enfin une seule attestation sur
l'honneur sera fournir par les parents
concernant la réalisation de ces auto
test modification de ce protocole à deux
jours d'une mobilisation les syndicats
d'enseignants appellent à la grève ce
jeudi pour dénoncer un protocole
intenable dans les écoles est du côté
des élus l'inquiétude règne également
sur twitter ce lundi jean baptiste à
monique se questionner par exemple sur
la continuité des services publics la
politique de test n'est plus tôt nam
nous ne tiendrons pas longtemps avec les
écoles affirmé le maire de villepreux ou
une école et plusieurs classes sont
fermées et où de plus en plus d'absences
sont recensés parmi les atsem et les
animateurs au lendemain des annonces du
premier ministre voici sa réaction je
salue évidemment ce qui a été annoncé
hier par le premier ministre c'est à
dire de pouvoir
uniquement passer à des autotests pour
des trois tests
ça ne règle pas tout évidemment mais
j'espère que ça va apporter un petit peu
de souplesse notamment pour le quotidien
des familles qui étaient devenus depuis
ces derniers jours un véritable enfer il
faut quand même il faut quand même bien
les choses telles qu'elles sont ce que
ça ne résout pas juste pour conclure et
dessus c'est évidemment le fait que les
enfants vont devoir continuer à être
testées assez fréquemment moi je me pose
quand même réellement la question de ce
jusqu'au boutisme sur l'ouverture des
écoles sachant que j'ai suis extrêmement
favorable mais quand je vois ce qui se
passe concrètement sur le terrain je
m'interroge pas ce que je vois que les
continuité pédagogique sont perturbés et
que finalement on demande aujourd'hui
aux enseignants aux animateurs de
centres de loisirs de faire de la
garderie d'enfants
évidemment à l'heure où on a les parents
qui sont aussi en télétravail 3 à 4
jours donc la situation est complexe
pour tout le monde et je vous rappelle
donc les enseignants appellent à la
grève ce jeudi un mouvement qui
s'annonce suivi conséquence l'accueil de
votre enfant pourrait être perturbé à
l'école nous ferons le point demain
mercredi dans le journal sur les
prévisions dans les communes un niveau
de réserves critiqué des chiffres jamais
connu depuis la création de
l'établissement français du sang il ya
22 ans au niveau national moins de 80
mille poches de globules rouges sont à
ce jour disponibles alors qu'il en
faudrait au minimum 100 mille ont fait
le point sur la situation avec le
directeur de le fs ile de france
interrogé par mélanie poker
[Musique]
nous sommes tout autant touchée que les
autres régions la situation est
difficile dans l'ensemble des régions
dans la mesure où le ffs est un
établissement unique et nous avons un
maillage territorial qui fait que
l'ensemble des établissements sont
reliés entre eux et en permanence nos
stocks sont équilibrés pour qu'ils
soient eux correct en tout cas le plus
corrects possibles
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est à
dire qu'actuellement nous partageons
collectivement la pénurie
le pratiquons à peu près 70 % de notre
collecte en dehors de l'eau mur dans les
communes ou les salles communales dans
les entreprises dans les écoles dans les
universités les salles communales
pendant un temps était difficilement
accessible tout simplement parce
qu'elles étaient
réquisitionnés pour réaliser des centres
de vaccination des centres de dépistage
le télétravail c'est très largement
développé dans les entreprises qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand nous allons dans
des entreprises qui sont généralement
des entreprises très généreuse eh bien
nous ne retrouvons confrontés à des
niveaux de télétravail extrêmement
importants qui font que les donneurs ne
sont pas présents
[Musique]
sur les deux premières semaines du mois
de janvier quarante salariés de
l'établissement renoncer à leurs congés
quarante salariés ont relancé entre un
jour de congé une semaine de congés pour
que tous les jours de la semaine nous
puissions organiser une collecte
supplémentaire
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également cet énorme
escroquerie révélée par le parquet de
caen un couple habitant des yvelines
aurait pendant plusieurs mois détourné
des milliers de litres de carburant un
dispositif technique permettait à
l'homme de 33 ans et sa compagne de 28
ans de ne payer qu'une petite partie des
plein effectué il aurait agi dans l'eure
la seine maritime et les yvelines
montant total du préjudice 88 1000 euros
pour environ 64 mille litres de
carburant à lors de la perquisition du
domicile des deux individus la police a
découvert une somme importante en
liquide des jeux de plaques
d'immatriculation des pompes est bidon
les véhicules concernés ont été saisis
une information pour escroquerie en
bande organisée a été ouverte les deux
personnes ont été déférées vendredi par
le parquet de caen
[Musique]
combien sommes-nous d'habitants dans les
yvelines lindsay répondu à cette
question en dévoilant ses statistiques
sur l'évolution de la population dans le
département quelles sont les villes qui
ont vu leur population au bc qui sont
celles au contraire qu'ils ont vu leur
population augmenter les détails dans ce
sujet de michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
je
bon
à
[Musique]
oh
ans
[Musique]
oh
et on parle justement de ce sujet avec
mustapha toit hier bonsoir bonsoir est
avec nous par visioconférence vous êtes
le directeur régional adjoint de l'insee
ile-de-france l'institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques et
vous êtes également le chef du service
des études et de la diffusion alors le
sujet le disait mustapha thoër les
yvelines comptant en 2010 9,1 millions
448000 207 habitants soit une
progression de 0,3 pour cent depuis 2013
comment ça se calcule ça se calcule
justement cette évolution démographique
comment travail l'insee
diffusées ces données sur l'évolution de
la population s'appuie sur l'opération
du recensement donc le recensement de la
population consiste en fait à interroger
chaque année une partie de la population
on ne réalise plus depuis 2004 de
recensement général on interroge un
bouddha population chaque année en fait
le goût en question si un cinquième de
la population
dans les communes de moins de 10000
habitants on réalise un recensement
exhaustif mais une fois tous les cinq
ans donc ça va être le cas dans les
yvelines par exemple de saint rémy les
chevreuse ou de vivre heureux dans les
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
on va faire un recensement par sondage
on va interroger chaque année une partie
de la population uniquement et ensuite
en combinant toutes ces données
collectées sur cinq ans on est en mesure
de diffuser un rejet une population pour
l'année médiane concrètement le
recensement 2018 s'appuyer sur les
collectes qui allait de 2016 à 2020 et
avec le co vide on n'a pas pu réaliser
des enquêtes en 2021 et c'est pour ça
que on a diffusé des données qui porte
sur un cycle de six ans et non pas de
cinq ans c'est lié au report de
l'enquète de l'année dernière qui n'a
pas pu être réalisé donc habituellement
ça se fait sur 5 ans lassé sur 6 on l'a
compris avec cette crise sanitaire il ya
de donner aussi un qui sont importantes
c'est le solde migratoire et le solde
naturel c'est bien ça exactement en fait
quand on regarde comment évolue la
population d'un territoire donné deux
moteurs peuvent être
identifiés soit
le solde naturel est positif c'est à
dire que le territoire compte davantage
de naissances que de décès donc on parle
de salles d'eau naturelle en soi c'est
le solde migratoire qui explique la
hausse de la population un solde
migratoire positif correspond à un
territoire qui accueille davantage de
personnes qui n'en voient partir et
selon les territoires dans les yvelines
on va voir soit le solde naturel qui va
être positif soit le solde migratoire ou
parfois les deux dans les territoires
qui sont les plus dynamiques
pourquoi est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'étudier justement ces évolutions
démographiques alors sur cinq ans
habituellement là c'est sur six ans
finalement c'est une période qui est ni
trop long ni trop courtes ça permet
d'avoir un indicateur assez fiable
en fait oui tout à fait ça permet
d'avoir des évolutions fiable comme le
recensement correspond en fait à
l'empilement de plusieurs enquêtes de
annuel on a besoin de comparer des
recensements qui ne qui n'ont pas un
comme un damné de collecte et c'est pour
ça que on va comparer les données du
recensement 2010 9 qui porte sur les
collectes qui vont de 2016 à 2020 au
recensement 2013 qui l'a porté sur les
collectes de 2011 à 2015 il faut pas que
les pères de collecte se chevauchent
pour que les
évolutions calculé soient les plus
fiables possibles et vous pour les
peuples oui à l'elysée c'est à dire pour
des communes les populations légales
vont conditionner
les dotations globales de fonctionnement
donc il ya des enjeux financiers une
commune à des notations qui sont liés en
fait à sa population à moyen terme la
population va permettre de réaliser des
projections de population en fait en
regardant la population d'un territoire
à aïda donné on peut regarder justement
comment elle évolue comment elle est
susceptible d'évoluer et on peut se
poser des questions sur les équipements
dans la commune est ce qu'il faut
construire des écoles est-ce qu'il faut
construire des ehpad ce sont des
questions pour lesquelles
les données de l'insee sont extrêmement
utiles dernière question sur la méthode
et on va passer aussi au volet
explications voire un petit peu comment
expliquer ces chiffres pourquoi ce
décalage entre 2010 f et 2022 est ce que
c'est dû aussi à la crise sanitaire et
vous lisiez aussi le temps de compiler
toutes ces données ça prend aussi du
temps on imagine est exactement en fait
comme on en a besoin de cinq années
une fois qu'on aura collecté ces 5
ces cinq années on va considérer que les
données qu'on va diffuser vont être
relatives à l'année médiane en fait donc
on est forcément un peu en retard mais
l'avantagé c'est qu'on est en mesure de
diffuser des données nation tous les ans
ce qu'on ne faisait pas auparavant quand
le recensement exhaustif et qu'on a
interrogé une année donnée toute la
population mais c'était une opération
tellement notre qu'on pouvait pas le
faire tous les ans et donc on le faisait
tous les 8 9 10 ans et l'insee depuis
2004 a fait le choix donc de ce
recensement un tournant qui permet
encore une fois de diffuser des données
chaque année si on regarde de plus près
ces chiffres justement pour la période
2013 à 2019 on a on voit donc que dans
les yvelines et une hausse de 0,3 pour
cent qui est assez similaire finalement
à la tendance francilienne qui elle de
+0 4% waka deus partout en ile de france
finalement c'est que dans la ville de
paris où la population a décru entre
2013 et 2019 comment les expliquent ces
tendances justement qui est un tout
petit peu plus d'habitants dans la
région francilienne est au contraire un
peu moins dans la ville parisienne
effectivement paris depuis 2011 1012
perd des habitants ce qu'on voit en fait
est que les habitants qui quittent la
capitale pour une grande partie d'entre
eux restent en région ile de france et
on a en fait un phénomène qui
s'apparente à des sauts de puce les
parisiens plébiscite par ces titres la
capitale le département des
hauts-de-seine et de manière générale
les départements de la petite couronne
val-de-marne et la seine-saint-denis et
les habitants des hauts de seine qui
quitte aussi en fait en nombre assez
important leur département avons
privilégié les yvelines et quand on
regarde ce qui se passe dans les
yvelines on voit que les yvelinois vont
pour une partie d'entre eux privilégier
les départements limitrophes de leurs de
l'eure et loire par exemple donc on a
ces phénomènes de ce qu est ce qui fait
que paris perd des habitants dans les
autres territoires on a un sage de
naturel qui est suffisamment élevés pour
permettre une hausse de la population
mais si on regarde uniquement les
mouvements migratoires on se rendrait
compte que les yvelines comme les hauts
de seine sont déficitaires par rapport
aux autres territoires qui les entoure
on voit aussi que les communes rurales
sont de plus en plus plébiscité avec des
hausses assez significative la ville de
la commune de flacourt qu'à une hausse
de 5,2 pour cent sur la période elles
sont plus en plus plébiscité on le voit
ces communes rurales là c'est le cas
aussi pour le département des yvelines
est effectivement quand on regarde les
données dans le détail on se rend compte
que les territoires les plus ruraux
comme le pays où d'année par exemple la
haute vallée de chevreuse sont des
territoires qui attirent davantage
d'habitants donc le solde migratoire y
est positif et à linverse on a des
endroits comme la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui perdent
des habitants
du au jeu des migrations résidentielles
et pour lesquels finalement là la
démographie se maintient grâce aux
naissances qui sont plus importantes que
les décès mais effectivement les
territoires ruraux sont
attractifs du point de vue résidentiel
là on parle du recensement de la
population 2019 on n'a pas encore les
données post crise qui nous permettrait
de confirmer la tendance il faut
attendre un peu avant de se prononcer
sur cette période de post crise oui
justement dernière question n'a pas une
boule de cristal on ne voit pas dans
l'avenir mais est ce qu'on pourrait
penser que cette tendance pourrait se
poursuivre justement on a vu pendant les
différents confinement des habitants
fuir les villes et aller davantage vers
des maisons avec jardin c'est le cas
dans les yvelines il ya déjà de
nombreuses possibilités en la matière
mais ce qu'on pourrait voir cette
tendance se poursuive et devoirs des
personnes venir par exemple dans les
départements de grande couronne
alors c'est une hypothèse qui est
hautement crédible d'autant qu'on
assiste à un développement massif du
télétravail en ile de france
on compte départ important de cadres qui
occupent des emplois très souvent
télétravail abl c'est une hypothèse
qu'il est crédible ce qu'on a vu par
exemple à la rentrée autour des écoles
c'est que on a effectivement une baisse
du nombre d'élèves inscrits par exemple
dans le premier degré une baisse qui
touche pas uniquement paris c'est à dire
que à l'échelle de l'île de france et
c'est un peu nouveau on a moins
d'enfants dans le premier degré et ça
concerne l'académie de créteil et de
versailles aussi n'a qu'à la cabine de
l'académie de paris donc peut-être que
des personnes enfin peut-être qu'on va
continuer à assister en fait à cet
étalement et ses sauts de puce en fait
mais avec des volumes qui serait plus
important encore il faut patienter je
dirais avant de répondre de manière
ferme à la question merci mustapha toit
hier pour toutes ces explications on y
voit un peu plus clair dans ces chiffres
merci beaucoup je le rappelle vous êtes
le directeur régional adjoint de l insee
ile de france également chef du service
est des études et de la diffusion
[Musique]
le sport il participe pour la 23e fois
au dakar l'yvelinois jean pierre garcin
et le co pilote pour cette édition de
lionel bocher ph sport à bord d'une
peugeot 3008
la compétition se déroule jusqu'à
vendredi en arabie saoudite
après l'étape numéro 9 de wadie haddad à
loisir conclu ce mardi à la 35e place
ils sont pour ils sont actuellement à la
48e place au classement général des
autos l'objectif c'est d'aller au bout
de cette course on le sait difficile et
terminer au moins dans le top 50 du
classement final
direction la commanderie de saint
quentin en yvelines avant de vous
laisser la plasticienne viviane sagnier
exposé depuis samedi et ce jusqu'au 20
février l'artiste propose une
installation visuelle et sonore les
détails dans ce sujet de bixente mayence
antilles ce débat des deux margot jésus
aux haltères spéc sion c'est le nom que
la plasticienne viviane sagnier a donné
à son installation jusqu'au 20 février
prochain elle investira la commanderie
de saint quentin en yvelines à travers
ces textiles entremêlés l'artiste
souhaite transmettre des émotions tout
l'espace est fait pour le public puisse
venir et
ressentir quelque chose est en fait ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que le public et
ce moment là c'est à dire que l'oeuvre
soit plus une un vecteur d'émotions est
un vecteur de senti plutôt que tout
simplement la traduction d'une émotion
quelconque initialement son oeuvre
invitait les visiteurs à toucher ses
formes mais il a fallu s'adapter mon
travail de manière générale et tactile
intégralement donc évidemment avec
l'occident n'a pas pu être possible tout
ce travail a été repensé pour qu'il soit
qu'ovide cinglé la plasticienne a
également été en résidence à la
commanderie l'organisation est fier
désormais de lui consacrer un espace
jeux les vues vraiment beaucoup
travaillé et je suis très heureuse enfin
pouvoir montrer son travail qui a été
vraiment pour le coup la pensée pour le
grand atelier dans la commanderie et je
trouve que c'est elle en a fait vraiment
un lieu magique j'espère que les gens
vont penser ça aussi l'installation est
liée à celle d'un autre artiste nicolas
henry le photographe plasticien et
metteur en scène y présente cabane
imaginaire et esprits de la nature un
vernissage de deux expositions est
prévue le 12 février prochain viviane
sagnier interprétera d'ailleurs une
performance dansée au milieu de son
installation
et dans un instant ne manquez pas le 7-8
culture présentée par célia gars tsongo
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]